have an update now to a story that our  eight news now i-team broke last week  the jury siding with pizza change sabaro  in a lawsuit from a once undocumented  worker who said that her restaurant  manager repeatedly sexually assaulted  her well in that lawsuit sandra perez  claimed her manager also threatened her  with deportation at the now closed  location which was inside the monte  carlo here's part of what she told the  i-team  nobody cares  and i'm the example that nobody cares  because i was screaming for help nobody  well apparently the jury is siding with  the company and the manager after a  10-day trial sabaro's ceo telling us  quote we are thankful that the jury  recognized sabaro's immediate and  thorough response when perez's  allegations were brought to our  attention the lawsuit had claimed the  company moved her to a second location  in retaliation we're still in awaiting a  response from her attorneys